what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this video I'll be discussing what
George R Mar once said about his
original outline and ending for A Song
of Ice and Fire now for those of you who
don't know George R Martin wrote an
outline where he described exactly what
would happen in his aong of Ice and Fire
novels he actually wrote this before he
even finished writing his first novel at
Game of Thrones all the way back in
1993 you can see the whole outline if
you look for it online now back when he
wrote this he had no way of knowing this
would ever see the light of day he ended
up revealing a lot of information
because as I said he had no reason to
believe this would be seen by millions
of his fans and ever since then his fans
have been debating about whether this
outline was real or not everyone wants
to know will A Song of Ice and Fire end
like Game of Thrones or will it look
like this original outline or maybe
something new although his story has
gone in a much different Direction what
makes this so fascinating is it gives us
some insight into where he originally
wanted to go with the Song of Ice and
Fire I can still remember how excited I
was when I first read this years ago
because I thought it gave us a glimpse
into how his Saga might end in his
original outline he even revealed who
his five main characters were and what
would happen to each of them by the end
he said five central characters will
make it through all three volumes
however growing from children to adults
and changing the world and themselves in
the process in a sense my Trilogy is
almost a generational Saga telling the
life stories of these five characters
who are three men and two women they are
Tyrion Lannister Daenerys Targaryen and
three of the children of Winterfell Arya
BR and the bastard Jon Snow they would
be his main focus and when he wrote this
outline back in 1993 he said they would
survive everything that happens in A
Song of Ice and Fire now this is
fascinating because although he did not
go in the same directions of this
outline I would say these five
characters are still the main focus
think about how Game of Thrones ended
for example other than Dany they were
the ones who were still standing at the
end they were able to survive everything
that happened in Game of Thrones now
fans are still having a big debate about
how George R Martin A Song of Ice and
Fire novels will end some say they will
end exactly like the show While others
say they will go in a very different
direction many fans also believe George
R Martin gave his ending to Game of
Thrones writers David and Dan and
therefore A Song of Ice and Fire will
have the same ending they believe exact
what we saw in Game of Thrones will also
happen in the Winds of Winter now I'm
not so sure about that myself I think
this original outline is a great example
of how he can change his mind over time
now I want you to see what George said
about the original outline he did admit
that it was real and he was angry when
it leaked online but then he gave us
some great insight into how he actually
writes and I believe he can help us
understand how he might end A Song of
Ice and Fire now before I show you what
he actually said I have to let all of
you know about this amazing new offer
I'd like I'd like to thank the sponsor
of today's video bepoke post bepoke post
is a monthly membership club delivering
a box of awesome topshelf goods from
under the radar Brands it's not only
free to join but you can also skip a
month or cancel anytime 90% of their
products come from small Brands many of
which are based right here in the United
States for example I absolutely love the
American barbecue rub in the carnivore
box and it's made by the Great American
Spice company in Rockford Michigan now
every month bepoke post introduces their
members to co new products including
Outdoor Gear bar Weare home and kitchen
goods clothing and even live oysters
that's based on a preference quiz you
fill out yourself every box of awesome
has around $70 worth of goods inside but
cost you only a fraction of that and you
can even review your boxes before they
ship you have the option to keep it swap
it for a different box or skip the month
entirely with no charge so you only pay
for the stuff you want some of my
favorite boxes have been the carnivore
box which came with an incredibly sharp
meat cleaver and the American barbecue
rubber in the Terra came with my
favorite Bare Bones knife with a sheath
a detox scrub bar and a Autobon bird
call and the trail box came with a Field
Box a gut hook knife the surviving The
Great Outdoors book by Brandon Leonard
and a pocket saw with nylon straps and a
paracord bracelet now to get 20% off
your first box of awesome click the link
in the description and enter the
checkout code th20 or go to bebook
post.com th20 you don't want to miss out
on this amazing offer once again I have
to thank bepoke Post for sponsoring
today's
video all right now let's have a look at
what George R Martin said about the
original outline as well as his insight
into how he's writing the story he said
I began writing these novels back in
1991 but I ended up setting them aside
to go work in television I started
writing them again in 1994 you know up
until then in my career as a writer I'd
always written the entire novel first
before I opted for sale I will admit
that it's unusual most Writers Do
chapters and an outline they write a few
chapters they outline the rest and then
they'll give that to the publisher to
basically see if they want it as some of
you may have noticed I'm not good with
deadlines and uh I'm not good with
outlines either so with fever dream and
Armageddon Rag and with dying on the
light in all my novels I wrote the
entire thing first without writing an
outline I didn't do chapters and
outlines I sat down I wrote a whole book
and I sent it to my agent and said look
here's a whole book and it's already
done that way I did not have to worry
about deadlines and it was finished
before it even went onto the market
and that always worked well for me and
my initial thought was to do A Song of
Ice and Fire the same way but what
happened was in 1994 when I started
writing them again I felt very enthused
about it and I said I do want to write
these Game of Thrones books next but I
was still in Hollywood and I just lost
all this groundwork on the show doorways
I was still stuck in this phase where
the studios and networks wanted to work
with me they were giving me offers about
writing movies and other shows and I
eventually did do some of those and I
thought oh God I got to set this This
Game of Thrones book aside again you
know when you think Hollywood they will
give you a deadline you know they say
here son write this movie we won it in 3
months so I said look if I want to get
back to being a novelist I'm going to
have to sell this even before it's done
so I had my 13 chapters of Game of
Thrones at the time but they wanted an
outline and I said I don't do outlines I
don't know what's going to happen I
figure it out as I go along and that's
how I always did it now what he said
right there is interesting because
that's what might be happening with the
ons of winter he said he always figures
it out as he goes along therefore the
Winds of Winter might not look anything
like what he gave to the Game of Thrones
writers then he goes on to say they
demanded an outline before they would
buy the first novel at Game of Thrones
so he said I wrote two pages a two-page
thing about what I thought would happen
it'll be a Trilogy it'll be three books
A Game of Thrones A Dance with Dragons
and the Winds of Winter those were the
three window titles and uh it'll be
three books and this will happen and
this will happen and this will happen
and I was making up and I had
thought that outline was long forgotten
because of course the books did sell
they sold for enough money that I didn't
have to take any more Hollywood games so
that's when I decided I'm going to write
these books and after a while I
basically disregarded the outline my
characters took me off in entirely
different direction so for 20 years I'd
forgotten about the outline even
existing that was until someone at
Harper Collins released it after they
got a new office building they didn't
even ask me if they could release it I
was Furious now this is also interesting
because he's basically saying nothing in
that outline mattered he said he was
making up therefore those five main
characters may not survive what happens
in A Song of Ice and Fire either like I
said earlier we know he had Daenerys
surviving yet she did not survive what
happened in Game of Thrones and we all
know many fans believe that same thing
will happen in the Winds of Winter or a
dream of spring if you ask me I don't
think those five characters are safe
anymore not only did Danny already die
in the show
but he's also already gone in very
different directions from what he wrote
in that outline we know Rob Stark did
not die in battle we know lady Catlin
did not die out beyond the wall and at
least as of right now John and Arya did
not have a romantic relationship so much
is already different now another thing I
do find interesting however is the fact
that George was so mad about the outline
getting out there if he made it all up
like he said and none of it was ever
going to happen then why did he get so
upset about everyone reading it of those
five characters George said would
survive there's really only one who we
can sort of guarantee and that would be
Bran Stark After Game of Thrones ended
it was revealed that it was George
himself who gave them the information
about BR becoming King everyone else on
that list very well could die after all
Jon is already dead and there's no
guarantee he will be back at least not
in the same sense or physical form as
before I guess I say all that to say no
one is really safe it doesn't matter
what happened in the outline or Game of
Thrones he said he figures things out as
he writes and as we all know he's been
writing the Winds of Winter for a very
long time it has been over a decade
since he had that sitdown with David and
Dan when he gave them some information
about his ending think about it like
this How likely is all that to have
remained the same after so much time has
gone by I would guarantee he's done
rewrite after rewrite since then and
that's why we still don't have the Winds
of Winter he still hasn't figured out
how he will end things himself
now we can make some educated guesses
but at the end of the day none of us
really know what will happen when it's
all said and done what happened in Game
of Thrones might not matter and what he
wrote in that outline might not matter
either however with that being said feel
free to let me know what you believe do
any of you believe those five characters
will still survive how many of you think
Game of Thrones and A Song of Ice and
Fire will have the same ending or do you
think we will see something entirely new
and fresh leave your thoughts down below
as always I have to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope you have a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye